[Music]
Father's Day is coming up it is a big
day we're Father's you know it's big day
for us and I'm very lucky I got a great
relationship with my dad but recently
this is sad I learned that one of our
cameramen hasn't spoken to his father in
over 20 years is that is that the case
Gary yeah it's true like I haven't
spoken to my dad and then like 23 years
I think that's just a terrible do you
know what you'd say to him if you were
here right now
I sure do yeah I mean it's it's all I've
thought about for the last two decades
I know exactly what I'd say to my dad
well guess what now is your chance
you're kidding no I'm absolutely serious
this is crazy but Gary here's your dad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whether
[Applause]
hi son
wait a minute I'm sorry sir you're also
you're a cameraman on this show that's
right then then why did you just enter
through the curtain right now I was in
the can
oh good it's free
[Applause]
happy Father's Day for Bagwell's
high-capacity -
turn the clock back gonna plug that
you